good evening everybody
I chair the scrutiny committee
and I'm pleased to see everybody tonight
um
when we have council members of school
to get committed to talk to the mum
so
um and we we have the executive members
of the responsibility for helping games
writes
and we we have
wholesale Adrian Fisher who is senior
officer uh responsible for housing here
and a special welcome to the Housing
Association officers
this meeting
we're very pleased to see you all thank
you for sending in all the
holy um this meeting is being streamed
live I called some meetings
so uh comedy agenda tonight is
the important issue which concerns May
mainly those talents of Housing
Association within the Trafford
it doesn't
um
complete that because obviously the
rubber issues are with us
particularly better particular
housing stock
but before we get to the important
agenda outages we will just need to go
through very very quickly the normal
housekeeping but we have family again
and so
acting well on the agenda is attendance
um so have we had any pathologies
apologies have been received from
Council box
okay
item three separations of Interest
any members of any investigating
the right sorry yeah my apologies I'm
having a bit of an artery disaster
whilst this is going on to my apologies
yeah thank you chair uh just to declare
an interest in the savings meeting I am
in my daily job slash normal job I'm
employed by one of the University
providers that are present this evening
namely jigsaw homes thank you
okay I have credit title for his
questions from the public but we don't
hire me so we can move on
um straight to item five
um and that is traffic
housing stock
um and we have a report from the
executive member Dave flight it was
about that
and the senior officer every profession
and they they will set the scene
on this subject
and the committee was considered that
important
before the Housing Association officers
have introduced
thank you thank you chair
um I apologies if this is a little bit
mishap unfortunately everything that I
had set up is now displayed off my
screen so my apologies for that the
committee will be aware of the tragic
case of RRP shaft and the foreign
this case highlighted to the public and
government about some of the poor
housing standards that remain part of
many people's everyday lives
you will be aware following the
coroner's report additional Powers have
been given to the regulator and housing
Ombudsman who will also be aware that
the council itself does not own or
manage any housing stock in the borough
directly
this does not of course impede our
ability to take action against hazards
and we are committed to doing so you
will also note in the report that the
vast majority of complaints received
about hazards and those investigators
come through the private and rented
sector
this is certainly not a comment from the
general property conditions of either
privately rented or socially rented
properties
the reason we generally receive more
complaints from private renters is
because there is generally far fewer
options available to them
the vast majority of relative providers
of a formal complaints process
we will of course review advise and if
required investigate any reports of damp
molds or other hazards reported to us
directly
what I just wanted to do uh chair was
just make you aware of some figures that
we've had over the past uh 12 months or
so in relation to
complaints about housing standards in
both the private and registry of Art and
sector in the past 12 months we've had
234 complaints directly to us of these
uh 77 who are down to the model and
three were overcrowding we also do have
a case study I'm a good use case study
of a before and after from what the
council has done which we'd like to
share with you at some point this
evening as well
just to conclude chair under my watch is
the executive member responsible for
housing standards we will do everything
we can to drive up standard in all forms
of rented housing no one should have to
live with damp and mold or for that
matter any kind of accommodation that
you sort of standard
whilst I am pleased the government has
introduced more power to tackle this
issue if they were really serious about
housing standards they would actually
provide Financial Resources to local or
policies in order for us to tackle the
problem proactively
unfortunately as yet this funding has
not been forthcoming we say we therefore
despite wanting to do far more are
hamstrung by the very small amount of
resource we do have in this area however
good it is and it seems very good
this is of course not held by the 13
consecutive years of coastal local
building Finance in general
I'm also also add that the further delay
leaked out this week the renters
reformed her does not fill me with
confidence that they are taking anything
in relation to housing as seriously as I
could but thank you chair
make thank you
yes thank you chair
um and um thank you for the opportunity
to to speak the report um just to
explain that um we also have uh
colleagues here along so uh Suzanne went
occurred his regulatory services manager
and Nicola Leeds who's uh key leader
powerful housing standards and by the
comfort of the debate uh that they will
be available to answer any specific
questions to this area so it's a report
outlines
um we have we have around 16 000 social
homes in Trafford and whilst and that's
perhaps lower than some of the other
boroughs in Greater Manchester it still
forms a really important part of the
housing stock
and a particularly many vulnerable
households and those particularly in
housing need uh find their homes within
our registered providers stock so really
valuable contribution to housing overall
we
the power up
um whilst London quadrant so the
successor of what originally was uh
traffic's own Council housing Remains
the largest provider we're pleased that
there is a very broad spectrum of
registered providers within the borough
um with you know bath array of different
types of property sub-specialist
provision a lot of mainstream as well
um and you'll see from the report that
we have an ongoing process of liaison
with these organizations and a number of
standing bodies if you like and
certainly the way we prefer to work with
the relationship providers is through
that collaborative process
um and that process of ongoing liaison
and you'll see later further on the
report uh the way that of course we
really have responded particularly in
relation to uh Secretary of State's
initiative and also more recently the
council notion on Dan and mo
however the council is also a housing
regulator and it's really important that
to emphasize that we have those powers
and we exercise those
um in order to ensure that there is uh
proper and decent housing for the
residents of this Borough and you'll see
uh from section three the report that we
rely very heavily on the Housing Act in
2004 which established a system of
housing health and safety rating for
properties and this is what we employ
and as I say we'll be glad to explain
more about
um how that process works in practice is
necessary but that's what we use
day-to-day as Council rights outline
receiver a large number of complaints
mostly relating to uh disrepair some
relating to other situations as well and
of course even where we have damp and
mold
um uh present we may well have other
defects as well to be often in
symptomatic of a poor management of a
property so um often some of these
issues will be combined together and
then section 3.6 of the report
um just outlines uh the powers that are
available to the authority
um and as you can see there that there
are a number of tools that we can employ
um if it is necessary to take formal
action
um and we will do so
um on a regular basis or we may uh ahead
of that to be able to do secure that
um by um other intervention and my
character there's a report indicates
that some of those particularly uh I
think towards the end of the listing of
1985 act are perhaps only rarely used
but they nevertheless available should
we do so
um we outline the process of um how that
is
applied in
um 3.7 onwards
um and as Council writer who did too we
do have a case study available should
that be of interest to the committee so
we can demonstrate that where the
council does take action where we do
intervene where it's necessary then um
it can generate a really good outcome
for our residents thank you
thank you very much and is there any
questions
to them I mean I I yeah
it's just a very quick question if you
wouldn't mind and
on Section 3.7 and I I noticed that
um both of the tenants would have to
complete an online
um or is there any facility for another
form of complaints and I'm thinking the
people that have access to
um
okay yeah so it is I'm a very primarily
online if people have difficulty they
could go to uh the contact center or
another Council reception but our
experience is that most people are able
to deal with the online facility
yeah
Council has
and clearly they
um this is this issue is being
classified by the by the fuel price
I just wondered how much these
complaints
to the council
[Music]
and since
um being sexiest weight last year and we
give them a code in our system to start
preparing these complete we didn't have
a specific goal for dancing well so we
can't really look at the visit because
um but there's definitely been an
increase that has come in and I think
the cost of living crisis has
exacerbated that's quite a bit so
obviously when we're going out and doing
our inspections we're giving advice as
well as San Francisco to invite me for
and you know things that you might
benefit from offices
yeah
Council Bluffs
oh and there's lots of issues here
and uh to try and sum them up in in one
or two questions in no easy math I think
as the evening goes on I think I think
we'll get around
to all the issues
um
in the sense that we've invited the
housing associations in here to see
what's been happening now it's
particularly interested in what's been
happening since the coroner's report in
November of last year
um I am interested in what the council
have been doing since November of last
year what what has changed we would be
asking that the housing associations
label what do we feel because
I want to feel sense of
urgency within the council
it is quite frightening that that little
boy died and we certainly don't want
anything like that happening it's
foreign
Council and they had lots of policies
that have been checked out by members of
the
of the council and and and see to be
doing very very well
and yet this guy died so
can I get some reassurance what's what's
been happening it's November
thanks Council Lawson and through your
chair so
you can I mean like you don't have
absolute reassurance from easy but as
the responsible exact member that we are
determined to tackle this issue
um we don't accept poor housing
standards in this Borough and we will
not accept all the housing standards
prior to the foreigners reports and
after the coronation report there has
been an increase in dampen mold
complaints I think I'm correctly saying
that since the coroner's report it did
spark a number of complaints and of
course every complaint that we received
we will investigate
the investigation I'm sure one of the
officers are coming on the technical
details of the investigation but
um the investigation will take place
what comes out of the annual
investigation will depend on a number of
factors but from from suicide political
perspective absolutely we are committed
to dealing with housing stubs and making
sure that everyone has
um a good home safe home secure home
delivery I will go back to what I did
say in my opening though uh Council of
water which is just in relation to
Resource we have some fantastic offices
in this area but we don't have enough of
them
um our resources are stretched
to a ridiculous level so any further
funding that we can get from Central
governments and then putting their money
where their mouth is
um would be very much appreciated and
that would enable us to improve and
increase the service and be more
proactive as well thank you
can I just push you on that one
obviously we've got new powers and those
who will be very very important and
particularly saying
with W pounds and we we haven't got the
results to sort of
you know so so
we are talking about
so
I just wonder how we could get around
that and how are we lobbying the
government in terms of that particular
issue
yeah thank you chair just for clarity my
understanding is directly the local
Authority hasn't gotten how much Powers
the enhanced Powers has been given to
the social housing regulator
um and there has been some increased
Clauses within the housing Ombudsman
that that are available as a local
authorities our powers remain largely
the same as they were before there's
just obviously more emphasis in yourself
using those Powers as and when required
and and again uh chair that that is
something that can reassure you that we
will use
um as and when required because we
obviously do not want anything local
happening much now to happen in Trafford
okay
thank you chat um we're lucky to have
some registered providers here to engage
with later so just briefly inquire about
the private sector of rental so could
you give a feeling for when private
renters bring a complaint through the
council how responsive to the council
find private landlords in addressing
those problems and what sort of time
scale
can a private renter expect to cancel to
pursue things if the landlord does not
cooperate thank you
and so generally when we get a complaint
and we have a presented um
we will
um initially write it depends what the
the hazards that their complaints was up
or if it is things like dumping world we
generally write to the landlord in the
first instance and we send out what
color defects letter
um and generally that gives them 28 days
to make an inspection of the property
come back to ourselves and advise what
we're going to do about it obviously in
certain certain scientific complaints
about significant hazards that say
um you know significant fire hazards or
some things we might need to go out sort
of straight away
um but generally we give the opportunity
to one more to say to rectify themselves
and I would say they haven't got any
specific physics but I would say we get
a quite a good response rate of
landlords I would say a good 78 will
come back towards will apply that they
could be making inspection obviously
occasionally you'll have sort of tenancy
relations issues where maybe there's a
there's an issue going on behind the
scenes that we don't know about tenants
won't provide access but we can help
sort of mediate that and if they don't
come back to us within that time
um or you know if you just don't engage
at all or say they're not doing anything
then that's when we'll organize a
foreign
act so we'll go and we do the full HHS
assessment so we'll look it down for
more but we'll look at all the other
currently 28 houses that are there as
well so we do a whole house assessment
and we do try and work with the
landlords and get them to operate and
getting the works done but it is just a
case-by-case basis you know what is
causing the dam is it is penetrating is
it moral condensation issue if it's
something simple like putting insulation
in obviously with that's something that
could on really quickly whereas if it is
they've got rising down community
and things like that so it is very Case
by case but that's my general procedure
what's that
yeah thank you I mean we find it
astounding that some of these housing
associations are claiming there's no
category one
of cases in their stock I would be
interested to know have we got any plans
as a council to ask the housing
associations to share some of their data
at a more granular level
so that we can actually have our
officers look at this an independently
verify some of these claims that they're
making
yeah I mean I think that's something
I think we need to know if we are
willing to then take that on
it's not something we've done it is
something
um we we could do and we
um certainly could look at doing
um I think it would need to be a
discussion
between myself Adrian the rest of the
team is to
what resource
we have you know in order to do that it
would probably be a big fairly big
project in order to get that going and
then obviously there would be
um some working gold I think what I
agree it's a good idea for a counselor
for us
um I agree it's something that we could
um could do I would just be concerned
about time and
availability of offices in order to do
so to be honest
um so certainly something I will I'll I
will ride back to you when we've had a
look into the councilor for Atticus okay
thank you
to me
and Jeff it's if it assists
um each of the organizations will have
had a left from the secretary of state
which may cross over with some of the uh
the type of work that Council Frost was
referring to so so it might be that that
is picked up in
um in in there might be something to
explore but later thank you thank you
the councilman Stanley
regulations because I read many horror
stories of in the private rental sector
because resonance very very reluctant to
come forward and complain about the
conditions in their houses because of
section 21. we're going to work the
officers do have they come across the
situations and the more General work
where they think that things are not
being reported because because tens are
concerned about being evicted okay
and we do get cases where tenants might
contractors for some advice
instances and say you know I've got this
problem in my house I don't want it I
don't need to contact the landlord yet
and obviously without the permission we
can't do
um but we do also find that we get a lot
of tenancy contact us after having a
section 21.
um because it starts to a point if
they've been living with you know more
than women for a year but now they've
been given the notice that they think oh
if we get involved potentially that I
can can stop it so
if we set an improvement on some of the
housing as it gives them and six months
whether landmarks are not allowed to
issue the section 21 currently and so it
does give them that protection just for
that six months that's only where I
would be achieving the Improvement
notice so obviously if they're coming
into us after it's been served on them
they don't have that protection
unfortunately but yeah we do on occasion
get tenants you know we don't use
concept and we just work it out fast
about what our rights are
yeah
all right thank you very much
okay
that's very much Activity questions
I think everybody is so
so
okay
uh no perhaps we can circulate it yeah
I mean it's probably self-explanatories
yeah
and
when we have
four I think uh president this evening
um
we're aware they've got to but uh and
and we've got
of all the information that we've been
provided
within good time
because we've all been able to sort of
them and therefore you won't need to do
any uh introductions I mean I think
we'll just moved on to to questions
We'll be asking those questions
um and if it could give it one by one
really
speaking to our officers um
I'm thinking about last year and the
current report what response have we
taken to the coroner's report on
properties have we found
um issues and have what improvements
that we've made
I don't I want to get that sense of
urgency I keep repeating that word I
want I want to know that we're taking
this seriously and that things have
changed I have to say I've been
disappointed
uh with some of the responses we've
received the the information that's came
about last night we had a pre-means and
I was saying to the colleagues that were
looking to uh to yourselves to to
explain your situations what my
colleagues were saying what we're
pointing out to me what what information
have been returned and some of it is a
bit thin to be frank
um we did ask for a case study a good
news storybook but not one of the
housing associations producer
so can you tell me what what you feel
you've done differently since November
what improvements have you made and to
address these issues because clearly and
I'm not gonna this is not it's a
complicated issue but I'd like to get
that sense of urgency this is what we're
doing now this is what was different
this what happened in Rochdale with
their policies can't happen here that's
what that's what I want to hear
systems
I I can suggest
ions
[Music]
I'm the head of a special projects
and hope and to just answer your
questions around what have we done what
is that sense of agency and we've done
quite a lot since South Carolina
taking questions so we now have a set of
animal policy previously to that because
procedure to support that policy policy
and for the whole of our colleagues
2013.
and what we've found from that is that
in the majority of the cases We are
following that process but we have had
also since the college Republic had
present forum and I guess there it is
and that did show us some surprising
figures a lot so much online not doing
it but the understanding isn't it
cases to us it is around the engagement
we do find that that is one of our
conversations
everywhere
after this year and to give more
intensive training around
the causes of danden mold the prevention
downtown and how to treat and I think we
there are
ventilation condensation but then there
is the whole people seeing things
internally
so there's a lot more work under there
and we're also now reviewing our
Standard Operating Center around case
management so when a UK support or
something involved we have a complete
closed Circle so we'll go and do the
assessment or work with the residence
[Music]
foreign
and so it goes up to every report on a
number of cases and open close to
indicated any closed cases
how many are still active and in that we
also include the academic category one
categories
well I'll just passed one question
how many of you did
actually finished
and you know the number of people
Republicans how many students
oh
I completed been reported and dealt with
oh okay so at the moment I thought
figures of the Active cases I don't have
those adaptation
we have currently 150 open cases
and that we're working on and they stay
open until the repairs are done and then
we're done for assessment
apparently happened
around about 9
over just under the ten thousand stuff
so we'll just cases you know who told us
about scrutiny reality residence group
that's foreign
you know I I try to engage with the
tenants lots of times it's difficult to
get them to people at the time I'm
interested in the attendance group I'm
not aware of how many um
but the one we did again is engagement
so I take one two weeks ago that he had
invited quality residence
and we only had six attemption so again
trying to get back up one month do you
think about scripted you're bored are
they are they actively seeking out this
information
[Music]
and
um
that we give we know also that down
below and tax weeks
so if you you would feel that you deal
with it more in a more proactive one
than it did previously
I would yes I do feel that yeah I do see
that maybe we are taking it a lot more
seriously comes out on the day-to-day
prepared and yeah and it's quite
separate yeah
okay
um
you've never want some coding the camera
I was improved
um it's better to say restart this
journey around two years ago around
Dunkin roll so the door has quite a
number of things in place at that point
in time so we've actually had done more
policy we've been out to
um
visit all our customers
customers to ask them to proactively to
have damper mold and if so this is how
you report it through
we enhance that in terms of probably
more options in terms of report an
example mold
all through you know the telephone calls
or letter or a web form as well very
dedicated disrepair team in place
um rather than going externals with more
control around that uh improve the
customer journey into the talking to
customers and the lawyers
um and we'd already put together a
dumping World task force specifically to
look at this now the so we're in a
fairly good position before the Rochdale
case from that point in time there are a
few additional things that we've done
not social response to that but a few
additional things including a dedicated
team to deliver the works so we're
delivering a work line of contractors
uh perhaps that point in time we now
build up our own internal Workforce uh
combination clusters electricians
roofers plumbers Etc to deal with it
that links to the um
bespoke case management system we've put
together with our ICT team which which
mirrors in lots of respects our
complaints case management system
in full the same process and that means
that once it picked up on was access to
data so
many of the organizations lots and lots
of good data it's not always easy to
access the different systems so because
it's specific called CRM system
means our data is far easy to access
they can cross-reference
I've done more cases of complaints or
stock conditioned service
far quicker and gives our monitoring
improvements
much like um lnq we report stats to our
customer services committee that our
customers on that group and have a look
at our customer Security Group we're a
part starts to board yes and they're
very proactive in terms of asking
questions around this because it's um
very high on their agenda
we have done some tweaks from boy
standards so we now look to install
additional extract plan
um in terms of pip fun
we also have
um tweaked out of stock permission
surveys
to identify the Asian condition of the
next track fans and sales
windows but we can actually do that in
terms of extract fans
we will also always if there is an
extract fan not working I'm missing
we'll replace our prepared straight away
um and just very recently so more
government guidance came out
it was last week actually
um so I'm just going to be reviewing
that to see if I've done more policy
should be amended on the back of that
thank you do you know
how many properties
199 the last 12 months
um
watching your report quality control
around
so imagine changes around policy a bit
interested in early doors and then we
put in a work in process that was going
to capture all eventualities of
feelings to capture that a lot of
retraining
staff
through our connect advisors make them
adopters
for ourselves
to capture every Junction that camping
world has been reported to us from there
we have now very scripted in time-bound
process of how we will address that
issue address if I will then follow it
up to make sure that it's been
eradicated and it's not
so as an example we offer advice and
augmentation issues there are call
center
and that after two weeks time we will
progress them back to see if that's been
it's helped if not we'll then arrange
technical Australia to go out after
something or just checking in a bit more
of them done and that will trigger again
so we're very much on the front floor of
contacting the resident again whereas
previously it would have been and we
dealt with something now it happens
again
that we own will go into that property
annually as part of the uh
and our Engineers are trained to
identify and help the models within the
property in a very good two LED two-way
LED conversation it's uh engaging with
the tenant walking around the home
asking them about them mold and
recording issues and making a basic
technical
then reviewed
daily back in the office and again from
that terms of course of action
that we take from there and like I say
we're very much on the front with it now
compared to 12 months ago and we've had
tennis grouping panels come in and look
at our processes our new policy and from
that it's been
worthwhile recommendations coming from
that we've just included an external
audit of our process and our data on
example we get to receive the outcome
and I'm a regular feeding internal in
terms of case management and I want to
say cases not just necessarily an out
dampen role case that's like example
it's all reported example of anything
from something very small in Mind
through to something that might more
substantial so we're assured that any
mentioned down for the mold in any
context the way you capture it and we're
able to
be productive
okay
um
scullery except director
Y
at a colleague who's the head of asset
management and compliance so uh very
much
he talks about going back to November
was a call to action called by Chief
exec
in response to that a number of things
were reviewed and strengthened if you
like around policy procedure awareness
across the whole home organization I
think it's a big big play around culture
that describing its own this issue and
showing that that message was was led
out across the organization
you know it's all levels so we've
followed a very similar panel against
the colleagues I think what were just a
few things to to uh at that time there
was recommendations
housing obviously about looking at the
spotlight report so it was a strong push
to towards that there was a requirement
at that point to respond to the
regulator in terms of our position
around how many hazards we had at that
time and then from that point uh
strengthening with our internal
reporting controls much like other
people have said that against one board
let's take about the exec yeah that's
that's you would imagine that's a
challenge screen of three through that
process with in addition to that other
Assurance controls in place we've had an
internal audit around that area excuse
me we've worked with a resident
scripture if I want to ask them to dive
in and look at that as much as one of
the organizations but we're on a journey
we want to do more more in that uh in
that sense obviously looking at
analyzing complaints that are coming
back you've talked before about the
complaint system processes that we have
in place and ensuring that we understand
what complaints uh we're getting through
what the learning is
I think a couple of other big areas are
the recommendations to get into your
homes and understand the condition of
the property so we know there's a big
push on that
and we've all probably worked hard to be
sure that our stock condition is known
so they're putting a lot more resourcing
into of taking stock conditioned surveys
and looking at being considered at that
but in between the frequency how how we
get an understanding of the condition of
things has changed so that looks like
jigsaw and said we have the opportunity
because we have our own direct works on
repairs and gas servicing which we go
every 12 months to use colleagues to go
in and I get to have a bit of like
things off crafts if people don't want
to report
to to import so we have a nice little
lane of assurance that if you like so uh
I think the sort of next steps around
this is a continuation we heard that
visit again
what that's saying in terms of further
best practices and evidence and things
that we need to you know we need to look
at so we'll be reviewing that I mean
thank you policies procedures training
and strengthening and we've brought
additional resources of aspects of
surveillance resource and capability uh
to get into to home so we're
strengthening that in that area quite
considerably in this including you know
additional trades brought into to help
us to put things right in hopes of slip
and shuts the place when we need to
there's there has been a bit out called
the social housing quality for the bid
uh that's been uh We've applied for it's
probably a number of organizations have
in this area that's successful in
getting some sums and that pays for the
work to be done it contributes
uh the high the properties with the
great opacity but that involved is not
going to be able to do every single
every single home but we're focusing on
those uh which are you know significant
number are in the chapter they're really
definitely working looking also again
we're happy to show you and show you
more about around what we're doing and
that's obviously largely focused around
improving destination
to ensure the customers engaged and that
we we help them to do that because
specifically that question is walking
out the property up yeah
and so I think I think to sort of try to
get the flavor that so it's the point
that we have taken this really seriously
we have responsive and we continue yeah
I think I think if we can be useful to
have figures
uh actually carried out
of the last year compared to previous
years
okay
yeah
thank you chair just a question on the
but how do quality food what the feeling
issue there's an issue
yeah
how are we going to deliver it and you
know what properties we were going to
deliver it to
you and so she wouldn't be looking for
such a couple of government area
um
okay
lots of care
hello first of all apologies a little
bit late uh wonderful daughter that
forgot her bus pass for college so I had
to go from this side mostly where my
office is where do you decide and then
back I'm going to rush hour
um
they had a building defects
[Music]
about three months ago specifically
from onward homes over England I was
actually it was the same role of the
whole Northwest in order to manage the
dish repair and also building defects
and building defects is partly comes
down the mold but also slightly more
holistically I think covers larger
issues what we don't want to be doing is
just going into a property so right
we've dealt with that mold now onto the
next thing the idea is holistic
after repair issues in that property
whether it's the dissatisfaction make
sure everything's out there so suppose
that's a slightly different different
line
otherwise I'm going to tell you pretty
much the same as these guys have been
saying you know we started Moss care
around about November of last year when
things hits very soon for parlors
various different pots quite data-led
strategy so there's a lot of work done
looking at the purse histories and
that's the only requested finding
silence
because one of the big things that came
out you know find you silence so who are
the terms that aren't talking to you
about this stuff so it was popped into a
quite a large list for various different
data streams come over there as well as
looking at new and incoming doubt and
not cases from a businessman people were
bringing them to our attention and a
contact center via the repairs teams and
under internet and what we looked at is
a uh basically a planned program of
Works which is kind of where the
guidance from some of the regulated
stuff is coming from now as to how we
deal with this to do the long-term
strategic way being led by the data so
we've got one work stream that's sitting
down with on certain contractors and we
also have a more proactive and dynamic
work stream as well so any new cases
that come in are being attempted to
immediately as well we've taken on to
new building surveyors who don't sit
within the repairs team they sit
directly underneath myself
they're slightly more specialist a
little bit more trade they are all
appropriate traded with hsrs housing
safety rating scheme so they can assess
correctly and make sure that that's in
if they're in the property is safe to be
in the property I wouldn't need to be
away from that property immediately and
that gives a better grading on you know
where we need to be and when we need to
beat that so that's assisted greatly the
other thing that we're doing as well
just point of the interviews now is that
I felt that once we had the appropriate
surveying skills in place there's a
slightly softer side to some of this as
well which is more towards education
understanding and realistically how
associations work so rather than
recruiting a further building survey
we've actually put out for what is
effectively
slight surveillance position but with
more of a talent liaison aspect because
what we need to understand is you know
you said the building surveyor out
they're going to fix the problem with
the building but there are still going
to be various different areas that we
look at as associations where we need to
understand how the building is reacting
to where the somebody is inside that
building so that's what that person will
do rather than just throwing something
back to our tendency team they will work
with that person to understand are they
a few important so as an example do they
have some undisclosed issues that they
need something to talk to do they need
sign posting where do they need to go
rather than just feeling that we sort of
go I don't know we've done some work
we've fixed that here we found in great
we need to to nurse that and again as
various colleagues have mentioned this
is all my bespoke case management system
the key to that case management system
is I come from quite a legal background
I mean there's a lot of this repair so
our case management function works the
same for this repair it works the same
hole it works the same for complex it
means it's interchangeable
understandable
the business which is quite key to some
of this stuff keep yourself keep people
in line that they actually understand
and one case can be pushed or pulled and
transferred to the others so you're not
losing data on the way it means that
everything sits within the same line
um we've just recently been audited on
this this person's policy I did very
well um we're just waiting for something
now to go and sit in front of the board
to be signed off
um that's regards the the triage stages
which I was kind of my colleagues have
mentioned I'm not going to go into too
much diesel because it's
we really all talk about the same thing
really it's just the key slight
differences I think between what we're
doing which is the moralistic approach I
think of using this particular person to
iron out
the ones of a better word areas where
sense fail to mitigate the circumstances
that are in and understand why because
if we drop that that's that's going to
be a big one yeah work a little bit more
with them
thanks everybody for your answers um
I think it's just my opinion chair Dr
Phil I only had one person mention it
external art and that was jigsaw and
that's where I I like to see we should
all be going you know externally
Audits and uh if I'm wrong that's great
uh
our talents are interested in the
properties that that is evident and the
support that I'm sure that's the case
but I do like uh straight away an
external life it's taking place somebody
who's got no no issues at times
thank you
apologies aren't we we have that's what
I'm saying we haven't just gone through
external audit as well
uh policies I think as well as jigsaw
councilor John
thank you chair
um just on the thickest and we had the
Active cases for lnq and your digix or
Airline value
um
figures as well
uh yes I can provide those yeah so we
currently have 10 whatever classes new
Active cases and 84 that are now within
our planned program of Works across your
stock
I think I think for the
the others who have not accept that can
make
provide that data
um
thanks for that data
um what would be any kind of will you be
caught back publicly how many cases you
have would be reported back to the
council
so we know where to go
500.
computers
thank you I wanted to talk a little bit
about the surveying so lmq you're
obviously boasting got about 170 000
properties you okay wide and we're
looking at this program of 20 per year
I'm want some reassurance that that 20
this year is involved in London and the
next year it's 20 in southeast you know
we've got nine and a half thousand
properties with yourselves in Trafford
can we expect 1900 to be inspected to 20
per borrower or is it Australian
I know I'm not picking out people so
looking more broadly I mean yhg you said
it was sort of taking you five years to
do 90 that's great with there but why
another two and a half years to do the
last 10 oh well value's got ambitious
plans for 60 by March next year is that
realistic jigsaw we've got promises
there of annual assessment so more
broadly I'm interested in if whether we
need a little bit of a surge serving
here if we're looking at our biggest
provider of doing 20 per year if you I
don't know when you started it and where
the damper mold was part of the Trafford
Housing Trust before the merger that's
another five years before you've been to
the last house that doesn't line up with
what my colleague councilor Walter is
saying about the urgency so is there any
benefit to surging doing a little bit
extra in this first year just to get
through the numbers otherwise it could
be five years that's not urgent is it
thank you
oh there we go
um in a roundabout way I mean you've got
a number of associations
there are only a finite amount of
surveyors and I'm going to be completely
honest with you I receive CVS for
surveyors on a daily basis for various
different recruitment Consultants do I
think they're the quality of
surveillance that I want to be employing
to do some of this work not always
um I want the right people for the right
task because I want to make sure it's
done and I think there needs to be a
slight
um acknowledgment across the industry
that simply playing this by numbers and
flubbing houses with surveyors who are
perhaps not the task for doing this
doesn't achieve anything and will only
make the situation worse in the long run
it's going to be a fine balance because
we're all trying to pull in surveyors
from the same pots and it is an industry
at the moment that um
isn't being topped off by young people
joining that particular
and I mean that's congregently I mean I
work as an expert witness for the courts
as well we just simply do not see the
number of surveyors in the industry that
we used to so for me I want the quality
of surveys not the quantity of surveys
uh very easy to get the the quantity up
I think quite difficult to get the
quality
[Music]
um
or how that's
it so I I can't answer that directly
right now and we do cover 20 of our
stock each year and what that program
looks like I am I'm unable to give you
that now that my positions I can get
back to you on some of that and but but
you're right 20 at the stock of a large
Housing Association
and but what it does mean is that every
five years everyone both options to have
affordable stock positions only and
whilst five years is a long time all
conditions survey will give us what is
needed to be done in that property and
then let goes on to our plan program
is the only stock position is the 20 to
20 per year but we also have other
members of our staff meeting our
properties properties so they do report
back as well so we've got housing office
going in there we've got external
contractors internal contractors
so whilst they've got condition surveys
are only done 20 of the properties I do
get into our property
as well
just be clear
20 in traffic or through the questions
I don't know the answer
okay
this year yeah
it is
I just wanted to ask to um
around when we're going into properties
it's a current snapshot in that moment
in time so if you're going in
foreign
living concerns and therefore is
our homes and motivation so there's
other areas and teams within that I'm
here I'm sure the colleagues here as
well
it isn't just the property survey where
you identify
ing
thank you actually yeah part of my
question it got answered in the meantime
which was about um Workforce them and so
if an industry suddenly increases it's
not likely we've got a whole lot of
unemployed people or restrained I'm
wondering how long it will take to train
the people we need and and see that it's
largely been answered I might just ask
as well about what the legislative
Chiefs would help so I see people
mentioning the bedroom tags and things
like that what could we do you know not
us as a council what are the things you
need
that we can push for that would help to
solve this quickly
yeah so I think on the first point uh
yeah looking at uh I think as we all do
around the idea of reactions and
capabilities in-house we know this is
not something that's the short-term
issue so we have the opportunity to look
at how we can recruit train you know
develop people I think some of the
Sometimes some of the best people that
we've got exist in the organization uh
they come from backgrounds where
technically they can diagnose and have
good communication skills so those best
people exists in our businesses and so
there is opportunities to retrain the
backfield build those so I think in
terms of strategies that are available
to us that are things that we can get on
with that's another one one issue
because uh
Spears case uh doing that in a sort of
measured way so that you get the quality
as opposed to just getting the quantity
and Ticking ticking boxes so I think
that's sort of thing to see how we use
our in-house resources you know it's all
about we've got opportunities to access
property and I think often we see that's
one of the biggest challenges actually
is is getting into our when we get into
it we want to try doing as many things
in the home with the customers we
possibly can do so taking the
opportunity if that is to triage or
gather evidence that can help some of
the more technical that person is
going to come together and discuss them
into the guidance it's just been
published in the last uh the last couple
of weeks I think on the point
specifically about what we can do to how
we've seen uh we've talked to them I
think we've all sort of recognized the
limitations of the financial resourcing
uh we've had an opportunity from this
big process here to be able to draw some
funding that's going to be able to put
in place very quickly and have an
immediate impact around around that and
bring it together you know Across The
Wider city is about collaboration and
sharing about the world trying to reach
the same results have the same
challenges and dry things up and not be
able to deliver things so I think
there's a there's an element that we all
need around around that that enables us
to to be able to Resource things up and
have a sort of you know kind of short
term here on things well longer term
views I think someone that influencing
um will will always help to to kind of
move that forward
that just uh I think I'd agree that was
just sort of just to come in and just
sort of say again
uh I'm repeating why I actually said in
my interview with Moscow which was uh
it's all about training leading to
better triage leading to better trust
and you kind of go around the circle
with those those sort of three things
you you
repeating that Mantra
um so again it's about you know we
already have stuff out there we have uh
tenancy officers as an example they're
not building surveyors
but we can teach these people the basics
of what they need to be looking for so
they're getting into the building
surveyor rather than trying to burn
resources saying hello Mr building
surveyor we've got 9 000 houses try and
look at them
so it's that training for all staff
about understanding for all staff
leading to a triage report and um you
know again for ourselves the first point
of that is the the contact center
previously what was happening to the
context since we're doing a large piece
of triage well unfortunately you've got
a non-tactical person trying to describe
to another uncircle person a technical
issue doesn't work
so now they're going to be using a very
very basic form that they fell in this
Dynamic any of our members of staff can
fill that in certain stock goes as an
example one of the questions on there
and I did the training with them today
is do you have fans in your property do
they work
no right I'm going to raise a repair now
to get them he'll still get traded
elsewhere but we're just sweating those
these are the simple questions they'll
fill that form when it comes to my team
and then we've sent our administrators
on the same training on a training
course uh that the surveyors go so
they're receiving the same training and
they now go out with the surveyors once
a month even though the other one is
really just keeps them understanding so
when they're looking at photos or
they're speaking to attend the house is
in their mind not just the pictures and
then the third point of triage of course
is down to the surveillance so the idea
is having those layers and then hoping
and is hoping as well but some of this
is also taken on Via osmosis which I
think is something that's been lost
during everybody refocusing businesses
from from Kobe where all decentralized
usually you'd sit in an office and
everybody would be talking around and
you go oh that's the question personal
that's somebody and that's been lost as
well so this is this hold down the mold
is
a perfect storm in a way in the way that
it's happened after Covenant and with
certain little things to answer another
question that you asked what could you
assist with disrepair section 11. it's
about getting the solicitors on the
other side and that's Mr Right Where is
commented then nefarious practices
brought to task because they are not
there to help attendance
um you know I can't say the amount of
times more specifically I was working in
Bromwich where I'll be told by 10 so
I've been told by my solicitor not to
let you in the building
now we only have one option then as a as
a group these days now which is to look
at Junction proceedings if we're getting
that consistent but it's not something I
want to do with the vulnerable tenant
but we are getting to a point as a
sector where our hands are starting to
be forced up behind our backs because we
have to get into that property it's not
something that I want to be doing and
anything we can do is try and control
the practice of door knocking in the
various different areas canvassing
um you know particularly targeting
vulnerable sectors which they do would
be fantastic it needs some form of
control because it does have an effect
on what we're talking about as well
exciting
it is
being ignored quite frankly and I think
that does happen in a lot of cases and
you know
um
you have got a situation
so I think everybody has to learn the
lesson
you know somebody contact you to say
that something is
how to take action
you know that's the base you know it's
just basic basically Humanity
can I just um app question
and I think this question
um has actually been answered and
certainly by two of the uh providers but
the question is how many homes are
expected to know on an annual basis and
I don't mean the ones that
um
were due to complaints being made and
what percentage is that of your total
housing stock and I too was concerned
and as counselor plus pointed out
I know well the Q said that they would
do 20 sort of um
of Van Huntsman stock each year so
that's taking five years to get around
to a good property your Housing Trust
was the same I worked on that was going
to take seven and a half years I'm
concerned about the tenants that don't
complain and you know I'm concerned that
they will get lost if they don't
complain are they forgotten are they
missed and for whatever reason they
haven't complained and
foreign
visits
mold
there's no points that we've made around
that would be
um mold can grow very quickly
yeah so you may survey everything
inspiring and too much love is not
so we do rely on our customers informed
with that
I certainly support both made around
just repair cases as I manage how to
prepare legal teams very frustrated
and that's a lawyer in that scenario the
customer
very little um
in terms of compensation or anything
else or any conversation talk about that
and again we are looking at injunctions
in terms of accessing
Mary to get in to resolve it
um
the point I was going to make was around
and again if we didn't have an external
audit on as well and come from that
worked really well
um and we also
um
actively carry out these visits so we
could also the gas servicing relational
testing repairs and multiple different
activities to actually have property and
opportunity to report down for more not
just the stock positions tonight
members
this is just a new question is that a
right or try to do that later in the
carry on
because she didn't really just go
through yeah
absolutely
foreign
is how do we do that and this is our way
of trying to find those properties that
don't come to us and we've made a lot
more awareness for all of our front
lines out there started allowance
given that caretakers you know be aware
and and just the awareness of what that
involved into that if you see it you
notice it then you walk back and we've
got it
questions
um I guess we're putting the report
presentation of overall sub Edition
acquisition across stock is December 40
getting up to 60 at the end and uh
without the resource you know in place
to achieve that I think that the layers
we spoke about before we have access to
our property as well you know as gas
team you know well
organizations
quite a common approach to how we are
responding to these activities
Arrangements through those resources
pretty much going to give you the same
answer really it's a common approach the
only difference being that if you
remember earlier I mentioned we look
back through our data to find the
silence so if somebody hasn't phoned us
we've got that data
that's the reality of it you know we
could tell that something doesn't report
repair because there's no return history
so that was all when I mentioned that
planned program it works we're now going
back through and that's after acting
planned approach down then they're on
that list because we haven't heard from
them and they're wrapped higher on that
list we want to get into that property
it's uh it's quite often the ones you
hear from the most
actually you tend to find the least the
ones you've not heard from yeah there is
concern that's the opportunities
yes if the councilor's question wasn't
to do wrong okay
to talk about this
yeah
thank you Chad um there's a lot there
about raising awareness around
I think people understand the risk but
there is a
residence field sometimes it would be
blamed I think perhaps it's fair to say
in the past there's been in the
dismissive culture around Residential
Services given these cases obviously
going reported
sat and they fall through the cracks one
way or another and escaped surveys what
tactics have you got over the corner
sticking out specifically and get a true
picture
yeah
I could start yeah so uh
to try and ensure that we got the tone
of those things right so that we can
communicate those you know Across The
Wider organization so
best practice looks like it continued to
to look at that so so I think that
that's one aspect the the if you're
lucky fallback is if we're getting
complaints that's something we're keen
toward establish from customers if that
involves part of a complaint or a
dissatisfaction level that they feel
that maybe as a result of what we've
done we've not necessarily got that
right so we won't be looking and
continue to look at it as well as part
of that as part of an ongoing process
okay
yeah
just that again if you remember I
referred to earlier rather than just
having a surveyor in place within the
same having somebody else who doesn't
sit with Insanity that's the function
really of that person that's a little
bit of a test for Moscow seconds it's a
new thing to do uh it came out very well
in the audience that we were doing now
and it's something that I propose when I
worked at onward
um and we tested whilst we were onward
last oddly enough uh last year before
November
uh with some of the um the income the
finance officers about whether we could
upskill those and how to get that
communication over and I think that's
what it is about many residents tell us
very familiar with the building surveyor
can we get them so my mouth that's all
you know
and that's why so you know we need to
take a step back to the sector from that
and also remember that again I referred
to before there's an education piece to
be done
um I've been with lots of vulnerable
around the presidents in many different
vulnerabilities it's not just you know
one size fits all everybody goes in that
bed you know
you know Association is very guilty of
people moving into that property so for
example the lady I saw a couple of weeks
ago a young teenage mother
just come out of a care facility and
they give us some keys to a house
himself here's a house you live in this
now
they'll be sold out how to live in the
house or have they they've just gone
there's your house so and I think
there's a bigger piece I say it's a very
big piece that associations need to be
doing to start understanding that where
it sits possibly Not underneath my team
I don't know that it's certainly
something behind will be starting to
feed into at moscare and saying we want
to get better we have to understand uh
our tenants needs a lot more than we do
now and I think that goes across the
sector
and
have some kind of thanks Chad um Chad
referred to a pre-meeting where we
observed that we've got lots of
aggregated data my question is about
repeating issues at a property so are
there cases of dampening mold which are
recurring how your property is reported
it's addressed it's reported again is
addressed and repeat so how do we know
if there are repeating failing cases
on how to up his capture and address
this
okay we
think we have about more cases through a
case management
and and we can see from that has it been
reported before
so when that computer context sent out
more distance
if it has been involved in the last
three months or there's been two reports
investigation
rather than everybody
would be absolute be fairly simple
similar to
the last one
foreign
get down to the models
I can come in about one if that's okay
chair so um for the Trafford area with
199 for your housing group
um those cases vary
um I think it's fair to say so in terms
of what works are required it may well
be a it could be roof leak related it
may be politely related
it may be the
um extraction fans not working there
will be conversation related it could be
all kinds of different things in terms
of what the root cause of that
and we take action uh as necessary in
response to that not just physical works
but eventually important it may well be
there's there's conversation guidance to
be handled that because they're in the
property as well at the same time
um that helps answer the question
I can get that information for you
because it was a specificity of the
trumpets
do you do systematic inspections of your
property
and are there any interventions you
could take if spotted at an early stage
to rather do this in a more efficient
manner
yeah it's a bit like saying if you've
got a nice car you don't wait until it
breaks down it's how it fixed you know
it's uh I think that is the ultimate
goal of any Housing Association to get
to that is not quite as simple
as it looks
um there's been a loads of my colleagues
earlier
you've got a bunch of money to get to
that point because effectively what
you've got to do is survey everything
get everything to a certain then start
your periodic inspections uh there's one
Housing Association that did do that
down the Southwest once she gets herself
to that point you can then run the
reactive service which is going to come
out that day or a periodic inspection
service and Facebook Millions get
themselves to that problem and this has
been a movie two earlier we're currently
betting for funding uh you know to get
things in there isn't a lot of what we
discuss here we are as associations
still funding out the of the pots that
we've got there hasn't been any real
funding I would say from government in
any way shape or form Beyond things that
we can all bid for that's acknowledged
across the sector some of the issues
Beyond perhaps what's being told we
should be doing something about
a hard situation
can I just ask
what results is as each of your
organization for these attackers
[Music]
how many steps do you have purpose
yeah
it will vary of course and the numbers
I'm I can provide with you is across all
of your housing group not specifically
traffic reports so
um we're in the process of recruiting uh
16 uh operatives as I mentioned uh
previously
um we have 12 of those recruiting
operatives there's a bit similar to
recruiting surveyors in terms of lots of
organizations what we're seeing trades
particularly clusters and groupers Etc
so that's not straightforward we also
have
um a disrepair team which is four people
um three of them are paralegals who do
those cases and then we have
um a couple of surveyors
some of those resources that were
existing within the team not necessarily
all new results with the operatives are
um and the contract manager is also
additional obviously that does a lot of
passport
and the job has been advice around you
put your resource where the risk is it's
not straightforward it costs there's
lots of risk in housing associations but
that was there
thank you
that's a problem
they've used Housing Association
do you actually want to get
to
accept
um
so we do a lot of work within our QR
colleagues across
um
housing providers so as we spoke about
the beginning of November very much call
to action and that was felt going across
the park as well since then there's been
a lot of work that's been going on
there's a joints and don't know and
compensation action from which within it
um has some really really tangible
um time constrained actions
I thought some of the things we've
spoken about today have also discussed
with invested in that partnership so
supply chain constraints training
tackling stigma that cultural change
that's needed within housing
associations and
Charlie mom and charity MHP and Ian
hamburgers and recently showed that
information around the Burnham and the
gmca which is also influencer video
so a lot of work going on within the
most thousand providers another
Partnerships across
foreign
[Music]
I think
when you've got data
so if you know for the last year
compared to whether you would be really
helpful to actually
um
so any other questions
okay I will move on to how to sit which
is the electricity
yeah
and really it's
beautiful
yeah
if you could give that explain to it
um
no that's fine I think that's um
our approach uh naturally more recently
has been to look at what funding is
probably 10 approach and have a public
first approach in terms of works that we
do so that's insulation effectively and
we have been involved in um
the social housing decalbination from
waves there was two of them the first
one which was just uh recently completed
um of the 105 properties we did the 64
of those were in the Capital District
um we also specifically built away 02
um and the further 82 properties where
it works are complete and the Trafford
districts off the back of that and the
work streams uh
very typically has been um external
isolation of Loft insulation has been
some PV as well and where to it will be
similar the other area we've looked at
is using eco-friendly it typically is
cut it while insulation
um again that's a very situations it's
not equal for currently we've lost price
information around
um where our points in the district are
so we've got 1.56 properties
um which are required to be
um remediated to come to uh
typically they're all in ground D so it
could you could effectively change a few
lightables and some of them and get
yourself to Japan see that's fairly
straightforward work we have up until 20
30 to complete that work we're going to
do a year really at 2029 we're on track
to do so again it will significant
amounts of uh cash it's been putting up
business plan to achieve that it's not
it's no small feat
um and we're also looking at some of our
new build developments as a scheme in
openshaw
where we are looking to
um
build out some properties which are
different places
what that means
um one to 20 25 standards Net Zero
account but clearly as a I've shared
there are significant extra costs to
doing that uh naturally so
um so we're tackling it from both in
terms of existing stock only runs as
well
program
[Music]
and we have a decreasing number so and
from 2020 we've increased our set score
from 68.46 and it's now
671.21 which is a great news for us and
the main drivers have changed that was
around our good job vacations
as well that's and increase that score
it went quite a good place with a Retro
Fitness at the moment and we can also
taking public press approach and that
will be delivered
and we also have a sustainability
manager that sits in the Northwest
please and it works with exactly around
my work investing in my room to make
sure that engine members are needed into
education
yeah
Valley
sort of similar approach to one of those
who've mentioned we've got a an average
EPC racing with a 66.5 which is our ID
so there was some things that you can do
when parents were focused on ppcs 30
it's our primary opportunity
to say about um
within that we've got some different
property archetypes and people sensitive
challenges
so on sale West for example we've got
some results across War
things
[Music]
thank you
so I think I think the point conditions
of Energy Efficiency software in
modeling systems plans
Energy Efficiency
because there is very clearly a
relationship between between those
elements our investment programs so I
think probably probably common to what
I've been talking about before actually
I'm not trying to think about isolation
and trying to repair these bonus
components actually
simply thinking of focusing on what that
starts with which
Dimensions
yeah so yeah socializing becomes
probably
um
so I won't repeat soon
exactly so you know again very
responding Goods so unfortunately for
ourselves and msv the majority of our
properties in your area are actually
in a really fortified properties that
still exist below that again 2030 is our
Target date the main reason for those is
before these properties now where there
are specific issues again what size
doesn't fit on when it comes to
retrofits so these are all now
properties where it needs a little bit
more thought camera potential the other
thing I would say that sort of the
retrofit stuff is worth
buy retrofitting properties if they
aren't done properly and assessed
properly we don't do the retrofitting
you will get more so it is very
important that when it comes to just
simply doing this work again these
particular the harder properties that
we've now got left to correctly survey
and that goes back to what I was
mentioning before really understanding
the nuts involved in creating a problem
for ourselves we've got remaining but
yeah generally same as everybody else 45
to 2017.
and guess what
um yeah same as everyone else
set number of properties
performance
yeah they're very very quick question
it's just it's the whole idea the amount
of time you spend on trying to discrete
lots of money from central government
because one there the
social housing decarbonation fund how
much time you actually spent applying
for discrete boxes
a slightly leading questions
and it's a
[Music]
but you know this is you know
it's passive together this person I
referred to it earlier this year we are
effectively a bunch of people fighting
over pots of money for stuff that should
be big
but now essentially I mean this is you
know this is for the good of residence
and tenants and scrambling around as you
refer to competing for a pot of money to
do some work to houses that we want to
do is that really and I'll leave that
with you is that really the best way to
be doing things and that's not because
of anything that we're doing as
Association
just curious about what you can tend to
do to help I think into that
conversation coming in terms of can we
make it out and Bush and more
straightforward as you say we've spent
money on producing a bit not doing any
natural work in that scenario because
the same problems with me yeah there's a
good question yeah
thank you em
I was a little bit disappointed to be
honest that uh the Retro facing element
and and I guess the answer is going to
be it's all about government funding and
but you know the urgency we talked about
in the damn mall we have a real urgency
about getting to zero carbon
um and I guess I'm hearing about aiming
for EPCC in what seven or eight years
time it's it's nowhere near zero carbon
at all is is it um I didn't hear
anything I don't think about what your
electricity sources are so
um are you moving away from gas heating
gas cookers I don't know if you get to
choose what cookies people have I guess
as a mix
um what are you working with electricity
suppliers that excuse me the gym
prioritize Renewables and again I've
seen some mentions of people and
photovoltaic panel solar panels that
you'll be charging which is is welcome
but haven't seen for example brand
Source heat pumps which you know some of
those large
um lots of flats and stuff would
actually work really really well and so
I suppose I'm looking for some urgency
and some ambition here and that wasn't
really what I saw when I read the papers
and and on the funding I wondered if
people had off-the-shelf ready to go for
little beds I think I heard lnq say they
didn't apply for both of those so again
if there was that ambition and the
urgency surely we would if at all
possible have something in for every
single part of money there is so we're
really maxing out and where we go on
this thanks
around the process from the start
the funding levels have come down from
the first way quite significantly the
costs have gone up Supply and capacity I
think is obviously an element to supply
confidence and delivery of this so as
you go out to Market uh you know the
department there's a lack of longevity
on some of these these projects and
that's all from working as a main
contractor in the past what we always
saw from clients was longevity so we
could work with our supply chain
around but we saw this sort of thing not
being Talent
the public supplies and service
organizations but there's a southern
American Table organizations
that had consequences of putting their
social security Bills going up the
customers facing massive ramifications
of cost of living
anticipated and about having to go back
out
for people mindful of some of those
things and getting the sequence of
things around but that doesn't uh that's
not to to sort of communicate that we
are not seeing that together
yeah
I installed my first ground Source heat
pump uh in Cold War because I used to
live down there he sort of Association
down there and that was nearly 20 years
ago now
um they are very specific to certain
types of areas where they work well and
they lend themselves really the
technology lends yourselves to
um block heating basically so if you
have because the issue with that if you
then look across some of our residents
who would live in those type of
properties
some of the technology that goes behind
some of these things they don't grasp
very well
um a common thing we've just referred to
with Grandma slots particularly air
sources people will say my radiator is
not heating up fast enough
um
the problem is again it's a lot of talk
within governmental bodies about doing
this stuff the technology and the
standing of some of the technology in my
opinion isn't quite very it's the same
as EB charging it's very well saying
everyone should have an EV charger when
we've got lots of terrorist properties
and they're worth people to park a car
it's certain conversations that are
difficult you know and when you've got
uh people who have been used to
particular ways of heating a property
you put an air source heat pump in and
they fail to use it because Mrs Jones
wants to turn the heating on 30 to be
honest instantaneous
so this this there's two conversations
within that
this has to happen and so you need to be
educating and communicating that to
Residents that's the bit that doesn't
need to be Government funding
yeah thank you I have a few frustrations
I wondered how much you view it as a
poetry when you're comparing all the
other things you've got to do just sit
down with them that you're willing to go
to the dad
um and kind of following all of what
we've just been talking about how
popularizing of residence and how do you
encourage them I mean some of these
students can be distracted by underflow
installation for example I'm encouraging
people to change
which might be more manageable
it's something and I did tend to know
what I was Eco trials were and what was
the purpose of that and what you're
using that Eco travel for
I'll just say in terms of popularity
with residence it depends which types of
scheme we're doing and some of them are
I will be honest with you I'm not going
to be on the top
um iwi as an example internal wall
insulation is very
obvious a lot of disruption certainly at
least we've got certain property types
that's what we have to do
um to do this so not every retrofit
program you will lose from there quite
correctly is popular no matter how much
we explain it no matter how much and
bear in mind we have residents and
officers who do go out and explain the
benefits they go through the figures how
we're going to do these things
um it's again it's not easy taking in
our case sometimes solid War terrorist
houses and trying to effectively make
them a new build problem so it's not a
simple matter and it causes disturbance
so no it's not always popular
yeah
and I just get a simple
you know the proposition would refer to
the trial yeah
and especially uh settings
Society office uh
foreign is
a model to encourage people to be
interested in it and I still haven't
really had much about how you'll
encouraging people to be interested in
the subject and kind of engaging people
no okay
I think we just start now I work for me
release date and I made an investing
program and we are reading the area
offices
contractors and levels have been as
segments
what we're doing
[Music]
and I think
it will start to become more uh
engagement as yourself to see it
happening
and quite often one of them say because
how many students
it's not an immediate and so it's as
they start to see things
for example people
the only bit to uh after that was
probably around the um priorities
for our organizations it is a high
priority for us I'm sure I'm sure
um but we do have until 2030 to do the
work from some getting PCC
um and we have to manage our finances in
the right way so that's that's 25
million pounds to get to the point of
originally BCC and it's out between 20
and 25
000 per property to get an esteroid
carbon which will follow between 2013
2016 for yourself you mentioned after
mold here and other things we could work
on Fire and Building Safety
government
[Music]
thank you part of my questions just
answered that I was asking about the
current legislation your under and
requirements I asked one of your
officers which one last year and their
answer about EPC regulation was
registered providers are currently
excluded from the requirements not to
let properties at ratings e or F and
that's at a time of private work
restricted can I ask what you currently
allowed or not allowed to do and with
EPC rating properties and what the goals
are just a EPC C for 2013. yeah okay so
what's the current regime required you
know
[Music]
um
so I don't we have we get an HCC on all
of their properties before we let them
and I think the private limited sector
as you can say just saying there is but
we don't have one on and social housing
and we the aim is to move at epcs
yeah the 25th Target but currently no
target at all it doesn't matter how poor
rating is we can rent it foreign
[Music]
but can I thank you all for coming along
it's been really interesting
everybody seems to be trying as hard as
they can
um but but they we are going through
difficult times
everything to increase it as far as I
can see
um and you know I think we have to do
the best that we can I think
but this subject is
you know I think the more that we can
work together in terms of that the
better and you know we want to get rid
of the mold and the dancing's property
another goes around this rule of the
line to to live in that situation we all
know that so I think it is incompetent
to do because we can and I think if if
you can provide that data the robust
before
so thank you very much for coming along
[Music]
absolutely
foreign
to see relationship
um
[Music]
we always have a good relationship
thank you
and
[Music]
um
yeah so we would like a similar kind of
you know
partnership between us and I think
also we used to have members
memories on the board of CHT if I have
no members
and I think it's a big chance
accountability
it's something
it would give us something to hold on to
again
you know
you've laid out a few things
um
[Music]
I very much I've spoken twice I haven't
actually introduced myself because it's
very reminiscently and I'm Allison
healed I'm the Partnerships director at
the Northwest around here and I've
actually been working in social housing
in Trafford at the point where we did
have the stock transfer to Trafford
Housing Trust was actually an
anti-social Behavior officer
so that was followed by 18 years with a
Housing Trust and I'll see our merger
into
um q and produce this on very familiar
faces
now while the Partnerships role caused
the Northwest my main focus for the last
12 months and indeed into the future has
been very much so on great Manchester
specifically Trafford and there's a few
examples of that within the presentation
which I've read off right
the actual role was created by the then
tht board in Spring last year and that's
to ensure that there was a continued
highly visible strategic leader in
Trafford and the Northwest and that was
very hooked to other Island which was in
March this year
um
I report directly into our the chief of
deficit Fiona Fletcher Smith and I'm
involved in language strategic
conversations within the group feeding
in about Trafford greater Manchester and
Northwest view into those conversations
and I won't go through them all and
there are some details on the slide
there
and as I mentioned earlier and a lot of
work with why that brakes Manchester
social housing networks are great to
Manchester house providers Northern
housing Consortium and also have a lot
of work with the tripartite agreement
director so that's where the community
great expansion designer Authority
Facebook NHS and greatest Manchester
housing providers but supposedly the
main point of the conversation is to
move on to that ongoing relationship
between traffic coaches so so critical
and the roles
earlier this year Trafford council's
executive team and lmq we co-created the
terms of reference from our launched a
new joint strategic forum and the main
focus of that group which means
quarterly is to ensure that there is
that strategic oversight and discussion
on joint working initiatives and the
future direction for our very strong
partnership and there's a mix of core
members for that so and within traffic
Council we have the chief executive and
deputy chief executive and Richard Brown
director of place who've set on that
group and from lmq there's the director
of the business of the Northwest the
executive group directors for customer
and Property Services and myself and as
Partnerships that I like so
we are also jointly developing a
memorandum of understanding
framework for those future working
Arrangements between Trafford Council
and omq and what we're looking to do is
articulate that shared understanding of
vision and future partnership working
for which that strategic Forum will also
oversee and provide screens now
and the seats held on the slide there's
a number of areas focused with that form
cover a wide range of services and
initiatives so we talk about development
and communities Health Partnership and
indeed mental engagement ensuring that
there's only communication lines on
strategic and consistency issues
and then I just wanted to touch on the
Strategic relationships and Partnerships
with Trafford Council actually being
said
for the councils in which we operate we
probably have property and I think it's
just over 100 countries and
the the focus on Trafford
is
is really really important and it's a
key relationship and our chief executive
Fiona has been to business
a number of visits and obviously
that link back to the wider group
but as already mentioned the men
remember
random understandings are lots of ends
on them the memorandum of understanding
it's being developed what's key is that
we have a wider consultation as part of
that process and only going scrutiny
being a core area within that so I'd be
interesting to be healthy distribution
it connected illegal to feed into that
number I can understand them to ensure
that you've got those those comments
included within that
the director of new business for the
Northwest and myself and also hold
sessions with traffic elected members at
minimum twice yearly and we update on a
host of areas the areas are actually
very similar to the Strategic Forum that
I mentioned second ago and we also held
a session for you know elected members
earlier this year and we'll continue to
do so and the idea of that is provided
an overview 11 queue for really
important in detailing how we work with
Trafford Council and Advising of the the
best route of contact which include
dedicating
account and they also hold one-to-one or
group sessions
requested
along the main point of contact for the
traffic executive as well
I just want to spend on a couple of
examples on how our shared Community
priorities have really made a difference
in the last few months post alignment
with um here and following the amazing
work that those
are those Community clubs which will
show you aware of their jewelry and
since the code pandemic and the
unquestionable positive impact that they
have had we have committed to continue
jointly funding those communities on
Twitter at the council for the next two
Financial years which actually takes us
to March 2025 about 24 hours detailed on
on the slide there so apologies for that
and we'll also currently in conversation
about how we work
to build a partnership
um around the work of the poverty truth
commission and the report that was
launched a few months ago and then this
list of the really long sort of traffic
partnership session in particular myself
and the assistant chief executive have
been talking about that voice of lived
experience being a performance decision
making and how we ensure that isn't lost
am I always have something tangible on
what that partnership looks like in the
coming weeks but that also feeds into
the conversations we're having earlier
on some code
information
just to cover up your point in terms of
the elected member on the board so the
traffic Housing Trust board was the
standard at the point that we joined at
the OSU group and
it was actually until March this year
that the leader of the council was
indeed a member of the traffic housing
trustworld and to my knowledge that had
always been in the case I don't think
there was a time where there wasn't
sport
within lnq we actually follow the
National Housing Federation code for
governance on the board appointments and
what that does is it brings a
skills-based process competitive process
very similar to non-executive roles
within other organizations
um so that process is open to all and
when the recruitment is ongoing and I I
personally would encourage anybody from
Trafford dog race Manchester City to
join that process and
when recruitment is opened but that's
the reason why
[Music]
um
way that the group brought is formed and
recruited to within our computer is very
different about what China has
recognize that because it's different
um
that has always been
foreign
is that there are a number of areas that
we've set up since aligning and with and
becoming lmq so the Strategic Forum that
I mentioned the updates
the elective members sessions they're
all new initiatives that we've launched
since
coming apart the wide Development Group
and I'm very clean that we ensure that
that screen and that that relationship
continues and how exclusive play a role
within that in future performing part of
that about finding when they're under
the window
well in a sense I assume that the
membership
I'm going to make decisions
is there a membership
kind of partnership area
are they going to be making decisions
um
the association
available to make decisions
absolutely those those meetings and the
two initiatives that are covered towards
the end there are very
trafficked-centric so there are
differences in terms of the the services
that are provided Within
for our chapter customers in The Wider
Allen key of group so the worker
Foundation is very aligned to the
priorities of traffic Council and
therefore what customers are nursing
yeah
there was an elected member
board case the decision
now
well
what should be the Lord so that's just
kind of thing
would be interesting to know are the
elected members from other places on it
and of the 100 councils are we one of
the biggest or we won the smallest are
we in the middle in terms of how many
homes there are here so you know for
example if we're in the top 10 then
perhaps we have more of a case to be on
the board and and so on
and I will double check this and get
back to you if I understanding is that
the members of the board no member of
Allen Q scored is bad because of being
an elective member of a local Council
they've all been
um
in terms of the size of
the number of residents
one of the largest
and and
that that's that's why there is a need
for that ongoing relationship and also
that was why my role was identified to
try and keep that link between screws
and commences Council executive elected
members and feeding that back through to
the wide open directly to the regime has
access
thank you
um to be in my Bonnet over this too uh
I've got a press release Here dated
October 2019 saying Trafford housing
trusts will become a standalone
subsidiary of lnq retaining its own
board in Trafford can you tell us why
that's changed
can I just ask the source of that your
website
so I'm going to get a full response to
that as as the Align I wasn't in this
role at this point
um
but I do know that the cultures and the
executive
the funds to what that looked like in
the future did change which was
discussed and agreed at Trafford house
at Trafford housing because of board and
I can certainly get the detail when
those visitors were made I hope
um and we're obviously
yeah
Community funding what you do and I'm
writing them
can you imagine
things I just wanted to tell you how you
doing
so um
we do have an old bus Foundation until
the back end of this financial year
there was the community panel
we are expecting that to return what's
happened in the meal times that we've
been restructured across the whole point
in terms of the foundation and this new
teams that have been established
I'm working very closely is
um the
within traffic and County feedback
through to the designers
are waiting to do conversations with
this application
[Music]
and I say that because
it's like someone who's been a
scrutinized from a kind of neutral base
you know it wasn't it like a
professional and you think you need to
see it well the chief except depth to
Chief except corporate director of
employees partnership to director of
Northwest new business director of those
people if you like it being a an
ordinary person
is obviously a space there
for the people that are kind of
permanent there to decide which is a new
member is required but I don't think
it's reasonable for those permanent
members to discuss that and to be raised
a great person an army member of the
council is allowed to be there and
broadly represents the interests of the
council and the residents of the Forum
foreign
[Music]
I'll just say I'm on behalf of myself as
a as the exact member for housing that
um I think Ali Ali has been an excellent
appointment and as well really really
well with with me is that exact member
um that's not to say that you know I
don't ask difficult questions at times
and that's not to say that we've had
disagreements over periods
um but
um from from my perspective based on
what tht
were previously like from a liaison
perspective things have certainly
improved over the last 18 months or so
um
one of the one of the things I think
that is an improvement is this
there is no longer a Obsession when I
when I say to when I say to
um 201q now
um
have a talk about housing management
which is the least sexy part of the of
the business let's be honest there is
inside and I'll get a number of
complaints from the tenants of TFT
because they're not you know lack of
response to repairs Etc
um that you know I don't get this sort
of bulk response all the time anymore
which is why we've got a 97 customer
satisfaction rights you know which is
all well and good for those 97 sort of
customers but the three percent are
going to they want to can't really I'm
but I don't get that body response
anymore there is a far more integrated
approach from members in my view to
actually get their concerns across I'm
I'm not certainly not saying the things
that perfectly by any stretchy
imagination we still have an ongoing
um
agendas to deal with things
um absolutely but
um and then obviously that there are
other issues that have surfaced over the
last few months including the
underground reports
um which I know didn't affect Trafford
but obviously
um is one that I'll be discussing with
with Fiona fetch Fletcher Smith
Innovation at the beginning of October
um and
um and going forward obviously
reinsurances that come out of that that
those sort of practices won't be
continued into traffic I doubt go down
and that they certainly won't be
um
my and and time will tell in this
relationship to be honest
um as to
the commitment of lmq in Trafford you
know the proof welding in the body as as
time goes on
um
the commitment to not just developing in
traffic because we absolutely need the
homes in Trafford but also the
commitments the the current talents and
part of that we've already discussed
Behavior with it disabled with a down
the line of course and improving and
maintaining their current properties
from my perspective on a strategic level
things things as far as I'm going to all
the discussions that we're having and
and me being able to talk to us as well
that's a good level we'll see as things
progress
um over time whether that continues in
the other areas that we need to focus on
and the Improvement
thank you
very much
so I think LNG are you now the biggest
or the second biggest down Housing
Association second biggest and so I
guess if that comes economies of scale
and you presumably have more money than
any of the others although more property
to take care of and we've heard you have
a highly skilled board and can we expect
to see some leadership in terms of
decarbonization and really you know
stepping up the ambition and it
basically if you guys can't do it and we
can't really expect any others to do it
yeah amazing and we have got healthy
carbonization strategy that we're
working towards and we do get one
freeware technical fertilizers and the
funding that we did actually achieve
throughout it and work with Instagram so
we certainly will be opening these in
the way and we will see that that the
carbonization is something that we would
we would want to be leaving and and we
have also we've gone into that 15-year
partnership I think on their Palestinian
saying about you know getting our
supplies on the side to work with us and
giving them some success we've done that
by going into these 15-year Partnerships
with them so they know that we're going
to be working with them into the future
so we hope that that will lead us into
that being
um can you talk a bit more about the
future use of sale point and your
customer facing responsibilities going
forward
so
I I can certainly get a report career
around
the reception which I assume is
the the answer they're looking for so um
and Q now do not have a man's person's
reception uh at sail Point what we do
have is the
the ability to make appointments for
residents to come in to be very specific
purposes depending on what their query
is what we're finding was the football
two reception was very very low and due
to the way that we a lot of
organizations have started working post
the pandemic the people that needed to
be able to speak to us when I was
available so we found that due to the
remote control and insurance that I
think their appointments so there is no
customer
are there any plans to take it out into
the districts into the communities you
mentioned the community groups that
we've continued with the company before
work on that is there any scope there
for Christmas
there's certainly um appointments and
drop-ins that we have across the board
online it's a good example of that where
we have different offices basically with
partner
agencies as well to discuss
any concerns or issues that residents
may have we do have
um our housing officers and communities
um
in terms of actual physical offices
across the borough not not as they would
have been when I joined in 18 19 years
ago I think that's the case for a lot of
housing associations
um it's more about what's going to
customers and making that as easy as
possible and then also obviously having
services available increasingly online
increasing their preferred but ensuring
that we're going to work there may be
future plans across Travelers that are
not aware of so I will present
okay
yeah yeah
I mean just to say from my own Point
without three weeks a month ago had a
couple of pieces available to
it
so
appreciate that I hope it carries on
thank you
thank you I think what's critical is
that because of those lines of
communication open so don't remember
sessions get a lot of insight from your
life let's get a lot of questions as
well and that's that's how we ensure
that you know we're doing the right
things in the right places so people
that communication again is absolutely
all right
well thanks for that
um I think it is really important that
we continue with the relationship
um
I think we all
have issues
um you know from our residents around
social housing
people know
um and it is important that we
actually the politicism people to
actually don't capture uh
um
I think
that relationship and kind of scrutiny
mentioned scrutiny I think we would want
to work with you
um
uh
finishes our agenda
I think let's get taken two on the
agenda
yeah
I think I did yeah
unique in this I don't understand what
deferred minutes mean yeah it means that
have not been completed
because you know yeah
so they will be presented at the next
community
you yeah
does any other member have any concerns
about this approve that
um
so
um yeah thank you for coming and uh
um
[Music]
yes